[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is a long
anticipated episode on my part this is
Zach Levi who is hilarious and talented
and you are about to hear deeply deeply
brilliant he and I have been messaging
since pre-pan I think it was it's been
since pre-pan for him to come on the
show uh and I'm so glad we waited to do
it in person if you're watching this on
YouTube You'll see we got cozy on the
couch we had a blast and it was Non-Stop
and meaning brilliant interesting funny
I told him afterwards it was like a day
off for me I just got to listen and
absorb his his genius and his uh his uh
humor I'm gonna say his humor so it's a
really really fun chat if you don't know
Zach he's from the show Chuck he was
Chuck on Chuck he was Chuck on Chuck and
uh in Shazam and they're doing a new
Shazam the great comic book that made a
great movie Shazam uh and he is
incredible in that he's also for those
of you that have children or just love
Disney movies he's uh in the Tangled
I hear his voice a lot in the house when
Leela is watching Tangled so let's get
to it as quickly as possible for those
of you watching this I am in a hotel I'm
shooting something so I stole a little
time here to do this intro for you guys
but we recorded this episode a couple
weeks ago so it's in the good old usual
spot just a few things to plug up top go
to petehomes.com if you'd like to see me
I'm going to be in San Francisco
Portland Seattle Atlanta Charlotte and
Washington we're going to be adding new
dates uh Vancouver I believe and a few
other places coming up all of those
tickets will be on petehomes.com uh
thank you to everybody who came out to
Largo on Tuesday we do a show in the Los
Angeles in Los Angeles not the Los
Angeles area in Los Angeles go to
largo-la.com and you will see Pete
Holmes living at Largo we do it once a
month it's always incredible Whitmer
Thomas Rory Scoville Judd Apatow
incredible people are constantly doing
it Sandler Adam Sandler Silverman Sarah
Silverman just great people it's always
the highlight of my month Val and I
always make a date of it and uh we love
it so if you want to see that go to
Largo Dash
la.com and if you like this show the
best way to support it is to try a pizza
picks are our ads but they are called
Pizza picks because they are actually
things that I actually use and I
actually love like our friends at Living
Libations living Libations is a
beautiful and natural I'm going to say
high-end meaning high quality not high
price but high end high quality uh skin
care Hair Care Oral Care Dental Care
gums teeth all that stuff if you have
something on your body living my baby if
you have something on your body if you
have a body that's better living
Libations has a natural alternative to
the random chemical nightmares that
honestly for years I was putting all
over my skin putting into my body just
because I didn't know any better about
health Beauty and skin care but living
Libations makes Not only incredible and
effective exfoliants moisturizers
obviously you guys know I use their uh
Zen shave for shaving cream they work
wonderfully but you can look at the
ingredients and you actually will
recognize them there's no numbers like
72 die number eight B four six you don't
need the periodic table of the elements
to understand what's in it you'll
recognize the ingredients and they are
incredible incredible products we are a
top to bottom living Libations household
especially if you have kids we put the
love the sun zinc based skin Sun Care on
Leela or when she's going out to school
it's wonderful to have of sun protection
that we know is actually not filled with
chemicals that are terrible for you and
at night both Val and I use their best
skin ever
moisturizer which gets your skin looking
great feeling great wonderful way to end
the day before bed but this is a great
way to support the show whatever your
skin needs your face your body your eyes
your teeth babies children living
Libations has a premium natural and
wonderful product to replace whatever
you might just be buying at the pharmacy
that honestly is filled with stuff that
is toxic and not intended for cumin so
do your skin a favor and support the
show go to livinglibations.com and use
promo code gratitude weird and you'll
get 15 off everything you see there also
from our friends at Alpha Brain and on
it Alpha Brain is a neurotropic I swear
by it I've taken it every day two or
three pills a day for the past six seven
eight years now it is a huge secret
weapon if you do anything thing that
involves cognition involves creativity
involves memory Focus if you're in
school if you work hard with your brain
or if you are in a creative field Alpha
Brain is a huge huge huge game changer
for me I'm shooting something right now
and when it comes to memorizing lines
Alpha Brain is a huge huge help getting
that information in there there's Earth
grown ingredients as I always mention it
is not a stimulant it's not like
caffeine it doesn't get you up it just
gives your brain the nutrition that it
needs to focus and for recall and in my
case for creativity for years I haven't
done a podcast written a script on stand
up or shot something like I'm shooting
uh this week without taking some Alpha
Brain just to give my brain everything
it needs to perform at its absolute best
if you like it one tenth as much as I
like it it's going to change your life I
always have it in my car in my travel
bag like I'm traveling now in the
pockets of my coats it's it's always
with me because I absolutely absolutely
swear by it you will notice the
difference and if you want to give it a
try best way to know if you like it go
to on it
onnit.com weird you'll get 10 off
everything you see on that page all
right everybody enjoy this chat with
Zach Levi what a treat it was get
into it it'll be it'll be a mid
conversation beginning
what do you mean with the intellectually
graying sides I love oh man I'm just
kidding no no this is real oh it's oh
yeah like oh no I'm I'm down for my salt
and pepper I'm that's what I'm saying
I'm into it yeah I'm not like what kind
of dick would be like welcome to my
podcast are you aging
yeah kick it off you you no one does I
was gonna say no one does but you can
mirror what I'm doing
and I'm gonna do
feet up anyway
right well you're you're how tall are
you
yeah this is your couch we're tall guys
this is called a they are not a sponsor
Creighton Barrel Verano
crazy Creighton which sounds like a car
a little bit a Verano sounds a bit like
a car I have a Murano and then you sit
on the couch and it doesn't go anywhere
no it gets zero miles to the gallon zero
miles to the gallon but she's a beast
though she's deep seated deep yeah it's
it's you're like a good I like a good um
I like a good deep couch yeah yeah
because our legs are long you know what
I mean also I feel like a couch should
always double as a good bed buddy always
had I that famous comedian troubled
marriage
I've I have slept on this couch just as
it because it's great how long have you
had this couch this is I've had this
this okay so this is the Gosling okay uh
that'll give you an idea of how long
I've had this couch because they're
together
it was like from driver you're from
Drive yeah
he is the driver he is the driver in
drive but he's not baby driver no
if you like me went to see baby driver
thinking it was going to be like drive
not at all you're gonna walk out
completely different I did walk out you
walked out a baby driver does that make
me like I feel like you can't say that
no
what's a movie you walked out of give me
one must love dogs that's a great
example but no one's going to disagree
with that yeah uh Sonic no we stayed
Sonic 2 but my daughter wanted to leave
well did you really yeah yeah so suck it
Ben Ben Ben Schwartz the voice of bench
force is the voice of Sonic yeah you
didn't no I did not know that I assumed
no you know you're in our house constant
because of Tangled yeah buddy win it's
awesome and can I say I'm gonna say
again give me a little toe touch Gentle
Touch Gentle Touch
what a great performance thanks man as a
as a as a as a voice as a voice actor
yeah yeah
it doesn't matter that it's Disney
meaning it doesn't save it that it's
Disney it doesn't guarantee no that the
performance is going to be great no they
have a very good batting average but
there's a few Disney's because I watch
them all the time where I'm like it
couldn't be more obvious that they're
not together it couldn't be more obvious
that it's like yeah just kind of reading
off of a page and you bring uh that that
that man to life thanks man I appreciate
that yeah well look that that's a
testament to our writer our directors
like particularly the directors and the
producer who they're there every
Saturday they're there every session and
so they're really guiding you through
you know like because you're all you are
all always recording it separately so
right unless you're not Fantastic Mr Fox
and did they all do that together not
only did they do it together they did it
outside so if they're outside they're
outside wait what and you can tell you
can tell
uh Bob's Burgers records on sambla
assembly actually I think there's a few
I feel like I've heard like even um
like Family Guy will sometimes or The
Simpsons will sometimes yeah The
Simpsons does as well for the primaries
and then yeah like you'll there's no
shots fired tank is area but when I did
The Simpsons he wasn't there but then he
drops in like wherever he is living that
I'm every character on The Simpsons bro
life I mean and what a great what a
great gig it's a great what a great gig
to have been one of those lucky yeah
early actors early on on The Simpsons or
Family Guy Family Guy those guys get
paid pretty good too but yes to just
like bring these iconic characters to
life but also
you know a lot of them have their own
setups at their house where they can
just like record whatever whenever they
want yes Hank is stirring an Arnold Palm
a picture of Arnold Palmer with a wooden
spoon and then he goes I gotta go be mo
yeah I think it'll be mo real quick yeah
but not a poo anymore no more poo no
more no more poop get it hashtag it is
we get it it is what it is
you are woke uh actually I hate that I
said that because I do a lot of podcasts
well recently yeah where like I was like
the joke is the woke person
like and and comedians are supposed to
be like not well I don't even like I
don't know sensitive yeah I consider it
yeah I think look those are great
operative words it just sounds like a
joke book is a joke yeah woke's a joke
yeah but consider it is always in
fashion you can say it certainly should
be it's it's a conversation going but I
do yeah I do I do wonder if you know
like with a lot of things you know
something may have started with like a
good intention but then it like runs
yeah rampant and a muck and crazy and it
kind of becomes almost like a caricature
of itself sure and with wokeness I feel
like it definitely is kind of done that
you know I prefer the term meaning any I
would say awake is nice I like being I
would say anything that people are doing
yeah is gonna get goofy yeah because for
people because people are goofy because
people be goofy yeah absolutely so yes I
I but but I actually as my guest it's
super important that you know because I
haven't I've done shows recently where I
was like is is like the joke that I'm
uncomfortable that's not this show yeah
there you go I'm going to take that with
me you may do you want to I'm going to
take them what would you do like that
you can have a mug those are the mugs
too in the show oh fantastic yeah uh
uh what were we saying the couch I don't
know who cares being uh being you know
enlightened awake being awake people
yeah well you know it's funny I didn't
know you you just wrote a book this
sounds like late night TV we're still
just talking if you want another foot
high five to demonstrate how not locked
into this conversation this is why I
like podcasts so much is because they
are the antithesis to late night TV
that's right I have been fortunate to
have this incredible career in mine and
I've been fortunate to do late night
television to promote said career but I
have always had a really hard time with
it because it's just so canned it's also
canned like particularly the
pre-interview yeah I despise it because
it's I just want to be an authentic
person having an authentic conversation
yeah and when you you know for anybody
who's listening to this if you don't
already know this every single time
somebody goes on a late night talk show
you have this you're breaking a lot of
hearts with a with a producing with a
second a producer yes because every late
night talk show has various segments and
every one of those segments has a
producer yes meaning every guest has a
producer and you know we'll have and and
that will be the authentic conversation
it's like totally chill they're like how
was your summer you know what's going on
you have all these great com this great
little made me realize that's the
authentic that's the podcast that is the
podcast you you're you and the producer
shoot the [__] you shoot the [__] and
you talk about life and they get you
into a great area but they got you there
organically and then unfortunately on
The Late Night show then they're just
gonna go so I understand you had a thing
with a squirrel yeah right and you're
like ah [__] well but here but but my
problem even with that though like I'll
show up to late night shows and they say
so let's go over what you're going to
talk about and I always say no please
don't yeah I would rather we've already
we've already destroyed the the uh the
um the spontaneity of it okay yeah I was
going more of a metaphor for a song
we've destroyed the song yeah yeah yeah
um but yes the the song of it the
Cadence of it the the authenticity of it
you know the the spontaneity of it we've
we already know we're we're breaking
that up so at the very least please
don't tell me which of these anecdotes
we're going to talk about let them
happen organically in the moment but
then the problem is that
because I don't like going over that in
like you know the dressing room prior to
the interview then I'm not really
prepared to do that but um with the host
who's expecting me to answer it in an
exact specific way and so then the joke
can be flat yeah and then and then they
don't want me back on their show oh I
don't know I doubt that very much but
yeah having hosted a late night show
sometimes we want you to stick a landing
and that's when we know we're going to
commercial break but on our show uh not
to toot my own horn you have a lot of
freedom if no one's watching and that's
real like some of these things are
victims of their own success sure it's
like we we have to get these in because
Beyonce is playing a song like on our
show we had nowhere to go and nothing to
do so this would be the talk show but I
feel like organic conversation if you
have and this is also kind of what
boggles my mind if you have a talented
funny charismatic host which basically
all of these late night shows have yeah
yes why not just be that just do that
just have a conversation because they're
Road hypnotized they're doing too many
that that's true there is that but
that's the [__] job man like that's
the job I understand it's like but I
feel like Johnny Carson or like even
before Johnny who was um
or not before Johnny but like concurrent
with Johnny what was that guy's name he
was he was a little he wasn't late night
um I'm bad at this I'm so bad it's the
name at Sullivan no uh
is who is Ed Sullivan no
um no dick dick
dick no gosh dang it he had like that he
would have that he would have a sit down
it was like two chairs and a little
table between I know you mean he's
blonde kind of yeah kind of handsome you
don't really see on TV anymore but he
but he would have like all these
incredible guests I know who you mean
and they would just have conversations
yeah and even on this is where you'd see
like James Baldwin go off for 15.
exactly this is exactly what I'm talking
about and then even by the way even on
Johnny Carson even on even with Johnny
Carson even more Purge oh yeah he looked
like Ben Affleck in reindeer games
yeah yeah um
but even Carson I mean I'm sure they had
some for for a former version of the
interview but you can tell from the
interviews this is I think what what the
real kind of problem with late night or
whatever is which is
now it can't you can't afford for it to
not be constant funny right as opposed
to if you go back and watch like classic
Carson it's not jokes the whole time can
I say something yes uh just because I'm
agreeing so hard I'm raising my hand yes
dude this morning I was watching the
Peanuts cartoon like an old one from the
70s with Leela and a lot of the because
they are little vignettes they're not
sketches but they're vignettes a lot of
them just end it just Fades out yeah it
just kind of there's no meaning there
was a time Carson and peanuts are
happening at the same time yeah yeah
where we didn't have this like bright
and tight tits and teeth yeah Razzle
Dazzle end on a pop and on a pop and
when even when you're writing for shows
or doing TV shows it's like everything
everything's gotta have a huge everyone
knocked out has to have some massive
things yes and there's no just like even
this as recently as like Frasier
Frasier's the last show I know cheers
certainly did it as well where the blow
would just be like and it fades to Black
yeah
we have no patience for that whatsoever
and it's bleeding into
again that's why I like this podcast and
I I like podcasts in general because we
can go places and it goes nowhere and
isn't it weird that that becomes special
here let me stick The Landing it used to
be a world of Meandering nothingness
like going looking for the bathroom in a
restaurant and you find a hallway and it
just leads to Nowhere it just leads to a
wall that's what life felt like yeah
like and then you went to TV for and you
and and you it was novel if things were
like Poppy and fresh now everything's so
Poppy and fresh everything even us on
Instagram that what has become there's a
deficit of is authenticity and now we
sell that back to ourselves yeah does
that make sense it makes complete sense
listen we live in a world of hype I mean
it is hype hype High Pipe everything's
got to be the biggest and the best guys
it's the biggest and the best biggest in
the best that's right gotta have the
biggest anytime you're listening to
anybody use those types of words by the
way when they're not and there are a few
people out there not just Trump who has
that wasn't Trump that was my
respiration yeah
wow
but yeah everything there's there
and it's sad because honestly because in
the best you were saying well yeah yeah
but but it's sad because honestly it
wouldn't work if people didn't fall for
it and people fall for it they fall for
it every [__] day but if we if we
could somehow get people to recognize
that they're being lied to like this is
all just a big sales pitch all of it is
one massive sales pitch instead of
instead of them recognizing like yo
authentic people talk authentically and
they want to have authentic moments
well Carson again going back to all that
stuff to allow for there to be a
conversation they actually had way more
confidence in themselves as opposed to
the bit now it's all about the bit
because the networks and whomever all
afraid well if we don't if we don't keep
people
hysterically laughing before the
commercial break they're going to leave
us yeah as opposed to back in the day
when there was only three channels
anyway and no [__] TiVo no DVR right
and so what are you gonna do no
stay with Carson or you're not going to
stay with Carson right so he didn't have
this pressure to be like make sure we do
it up we're back to my show yeah I'm no
no [__] the reason why having a talk
show on TBS that nobody was watching was
great was because it was like that yeah
meaning we could do anything you could
do it so Carson used to have like Sammy
Davis Jr which is clearly just walk in
because he was shooting on the same lock
yeah like you and you could tell there
was no pre-interview and then just [__]
around and they're smoking and all that
sort of stuff and that was there but now
everything you were on a very
interesting area there about how
everything has been turned into a
product and it doesn't work is what you
were saying bigger and better doesn't
work I want to put this into your
clearly High processing brain is the
idea that Humanity doesn't know there's
a better uh alternative so what we've
settled for is this cat and mouse bait
and switch where it's better to live in
a world where the next product thing bit
of entertainment or manufactured moment
that's being sold to us might save us we
know it won't but living in the hope
that it might is better than just this
is not true but perceivably waiting
around to die that's not true yeah
that's not true we would rather just
stay on the on the treadmill and go oh
another thing failed us another thing
failed us it turns out it wasn't whiter
teeth it wasn't sparkling floors and it
wasn't not wider teeth and like even
things like Cameo have proven that if
Ben Affleck's star of reindeer games
goes like hey happy birthday Julian even
that doesn't work like it's not
I've done one one session on camera I
did it for charity one so it was the
only way that I was able to kind of
really wrap my head around it sure but
but here's the thing I also don't want
to disparage anybody who is using Cameo
or whatever I'm saying no you're not the
reason I mentioned it was even if the
entertainment is directed specifically
to you yeah or in the future let's take
Cameo out of it virtual reality puts you
in the movie totally and there you are
in the Shazam you're in fact you are
recast by them JK
[Laughter]
[Music]
CNN but you know what I'm saying I'm not
[__] on Cameo I'm [__] on I
don't think you are it doesn't matter
how your hard Show Business licks your
ass yeah yeah you're still gonna go like
huh well but you're making the you're
making the point which is which is that
it's all it's diminishing returns and
it's and and it's the same thing as and
you know these studies that have been
done which is you go and buy a new thing
you get a shot of dopamine yeah and by
the way it doesn't matter if you're the
uber wealthy guy who bought the lambo or
the person who doesn't have the money
and buys the Corolla can I tell you
something preach so I just wanna I just
want to say same feeling of dopamine
exact same time and it goes away yes
very very quickly much more quickly than
we'd like to realize and so the Cameo
where you are getting your you're a fan
getting your ass licked by whomever yes
that will hit like that and it'll go
away it goes away and then you end up as
a consumer whether it's of content or
product or whatever and you go oh I'm
still not happy and this means I need
more which means I'll fall for the
bright shiny packaging yes more because
that feels like it's got more promise to
lick my ass and that feeling is actually
what I think like like rats and Amaze
we've been conditioned to like the hope
that the next shiny box I'm sort of
doing it I've got it God forbid I I
can't
I can't fault myself if I am but
Christmas is coming up and Leela's real
excited about what's under the tree and
aren't I kind of subtly introducing the
idea this isn't enough it's what's under
the tree you know it's just it's just a
big part of our our culture but I like
what you were saying to get off my guilt
for a second yeah I'm just kidding we're
gonna go back to your guilt this is a
guilt camera
listen stew in the guild edit all of us
out and then edit it back in but at half
speeds it takes twice as long for you
and your daughter what I want to say is
I've seen as I'm sure you've seen and I
actually want you to talk about this if
you would
yeah the Uber Uber success the Uber
successful people same
same problems different uh ingredients
yeah what I'm saying is just you this is
what you're saying with the lambo you
either get a Lamborghini and realize
it's not enough for you get a crow and
realize it's not enough there's
something talk about what we're trying
to teach Leela
I I sometimes say to her I go baby when
do once end I know that's a crazy thing
to say to a child when does it end you
need to notice and recognize now that it
never ends there's a spiritual teacher
named sad Guru who oh yeah quite popular
here's an interesting thing where he
goes like let's say you did rule the
world you rule the world everything is
yours and everyone is in your service
how long before you go what about Mars
yeah that's just how it is
why do you think all the [__] Kings
and Empire or Emperors and all these
people who do not stop grabbing more
land and more people they can't go there
Caesar couldn't visit all of his
territories it was just a map no but you
you got that dopamine but he got that
dopamine he got every single time he got
another people group and and he had a
map and someone had to explain them you
now have these people Britain you now
have India it's a map it's a map and
we're a map of people and we're pyramid
people Val and I always say we're
pyramid people if you meaning if I gave
you Zach all this power yeah eventually
you'd build a pyramid this is what you
do we have no better ideas you're gonna
build a pyramid although let's put a pin
in pyramids because I I think pyramids
pyramids I'm just kidding they're still
crying invasive
no I really do I really do think that
that pyramids ancient civilizations and
all this [__] I watched this really
fascinating uh docu-series on Netflix
called um ancient apocalypse about
basically
um uh you know there was this
apocalyptic event that happened about 12
12 and a half thousand years ago and I
remember yeah I remember we were all
there uh and um no uh it's uh the
younger younger driest event is what it
is and it's basically when the earth got
in the way of a meteor field and we got
pummeled and that's essentially when the
end of the last ice age uh the the mark
the end of the last ice age and it
happened very rapidly which is why the
entire world flooded just like you know
like if you go back and talk about like
well well you know like alone for sure
but like all like not just you know Noah
and and the Ark is just the Israelites
or the Jewish kind of Mythology of that
same flood almost every every culture in
the world has right and it all ties back
to the same time and the pyramids all
started popping up around them and they
always by the way right before then you
mean no like like post post post-massive
flood almost as if in an attempt to
somehow either remember this Celestial
event but because if you look at the
pyramids they're all tied up straight to
the Stars like they're they're
alignments and all those things but also
those pyramids all over Latin America
there's pyramids all over
um other places in Europe Mexico
uh and and it was a great see it's hard
to say yes and in Spanish that's a good
CE man
Mexican improvisers rule number one
[Applause]
doesn't sound as good
don't forget C oh my God anyway yes so
we build these pyramids and we and we do
these things and we want to rule the
world and it's
CE take you off of it you're saying
they're building them oh no I don't know
to remember commemorate I think you're
gonna say it's high ground it's against
you no no no it's all these incredible
again if you go and watch you know the
stocky series it's really really
fascinating and these guys who kind of
talk walk you through it and there's
plenty of archaeological evidence by the
way that points to so many things that
modern day archeology has basically just
kind of turned their eyes from yeah and
you gotta have something they thought
they had it all figured out all the
modern like like mainstream
archaeologists all you know said all the
pyramids are this old and the Sphinx is
this old and and that's that we've we've
done it it's settled science or whatever
yeah yeah well now new evidence is
coming to light but they're all like no
no no no no no no this can't be because
their entire reputations are basically
because scientists are also pyramid
people well you want to be published
they want to and it's almost unconscious
yeah like your desire to be right or
whatever ever yeah is as much why people
fall for multi multi-level marketing
which is actually why I brought you here
I just I I just see I knew you were
going to sell me something that been
going well
it's just like an entire just merch like
brand the original you're gonna start
with pillows we're gonna work our way up
pillow oh you just hello hello I think
I'm more of a pillow guy I like a PE
like I think my whole life growing up I
pronounce it more pillows is that a
Louisiana thing no I grew up in Southern
California you started in Louisiana I I
was too I love that he's done
I was two months old my dad just
happened to be working there when I
popped out so okay I just it's on my
birth certificate and my driver's
license but I have no real connection to
the folks okay like Charles and you
don't care
I actually have some friends that live
in Lake Charles now but and I think
Louisiana is a state I think New Orleans
is a lot of fun I've really enjoyed that
place don't care for it uh I'll come
back to that
I'm probably going there soon yeah on
tour so I I am kidding but I I do get
scared when I when I'm there I don't
like that they're like this hotel's
haunted I'm like stop it stop it I don't
like it yeah the the the glorification
of like the voodooy scariness isn't my
favorite I gotcha it's like if I'm gonna
stay in a theme park it's not the
Haunted Mansion I I I'd rather stay in
Epcot I'm an Epcot boy wait you could
stay at the Haunted Mansion no I but in
this in this fly your mixing metaphors
here and I don't know that I appreciate
it
um but listen coming full circle all the
way back too let me talk about these
meteors oh we can talk about that too oh
[__] I can go all day about that stuff
but okay
um look yes we live in this just we live
in a
we live in this commoditized we live in
this shiny box world of shiny flashy
things that we're all now constantly
distracted by and all feel like and
while being programmed you need this you
need this you need this and if you
finally get it then you'll be happy and
you're not happy you know but if you
this you'll be happy if you get this you
you'll be happy and simultaneously it's
turned us into a disposable Society
everything that we do in our lives is
basically everything we buy everything
we watch it's all this disposable
garbage I mean it's insane it's speed
speed and speed agree I agree with you
quickly oh speed like I don't need any
more but I thought you said Speedy a
speedy greed and I was like which is
that too it's Speedy Green it's 80
degrees it's like you know it's like
Fast fashion yeah it's insane that you
know we talk about the environment which
we need to talk about we need to talk
about ways in which we can protect it
and protect ourselves and all the
animals and all of the life on this
planet which is really the only [__]
miracle by the way everything else is
replaceable or reproducible it's it's
life and life itself this is the only
real [__] miracle in this you know as
Carl Sagan puts on this little blue dot
spinning around in this vastness and we
don't protect it we we because we've all
you know because Industries all bought
and sold and all of our politicians are
all [__] bought and sold by the
industries through lobbyists and all
that [__] you can take that [__] to the
[__] bank but I'd like to take a
transcript of this conversation to a
bank
he said take it to the bank do you not
give me we'll put in a safe deposit box
and so and so all these industries have
all run amok and all they care about is
bottom lines it's the shareholders and
bottom lines right against our own
invest in against their own best
interest because if they actually did
give a [__] about their employees and
the quality of their product then they
would ultimately make more money and
have more loyal customers in the long
run right but they're all just like
right now I need it right [__] out
it's a speedy greed right well Speedy
greedy I'll sell you beef grazed in the
rainforest meaning I'll cut down my own
lungs yeah yeah yeah yeah the lungs of
the planet totally to sell you beef
today and we'll all yeah I'm not a I'm
not of the opinion that we'll all die
tomorrow but I was thinking today or I
was like there's sort of a narcissism
you're probably more informed than I am
to thinking that will destroy the Earth
I think it's far more likely that the
Earth will destroy us I I agree with
this you know what I'm saying I think
why isn't that the going Theory though
it's like like earthquakes floods
droughts all that stuff will have fires
will happen it'll kill us because the
Earth like an entity is like get these
[__] things off of me or maybe it's a
meteor bath you know what I'm saying I
mean by the way the chances of us
getting hit by another media are way
higher than people really know that's
one of those things like it's like that
might actually wipe us all out well
before the Oceans Rise I mean what do
you say that life uh and the way that
life has been going ancient apocalypse
style and I don't say this with fear I
say this with delight sure as a member
of Life capital l meaning
I used to have a joke where I was like
life will be okay I don't know if we'll
be okay yeah if Zach and Pete will be in
fact I can guarantee that Zack and Pete
will die we will die but life will be
okay and not to get too ahead of
ourselves that's who I believe I
actually am I am a member of life like I
am one isolated member of a thing that
will be okay so in that sense I can say
you will be okay yes but
I think it's it's even if we the new
king and all that stuff give it a few
billion years life life is not gonna I I
completely agree with you I I think uh
that doesn't mean we shouldn't try no no
it doesn't mean we shouldn't try but it
is interesting that the The Narrative is
we're killing the planet when the planet
we're gonna win way robust like the
planet has gone through way way more
horrible shooting but particularly these
meteors these meteors are the equivalent
of like hundreds and thousands of
nuclear explosions right like the Earth
and that's happened before and that's
happened multiple times yeah and life
still found a way not to quote the
dinosaur movie like Jurassic Park but uh
life finds a way and life did find a way
in life it's a family movie and life
will find a way again I completely agree
I think the reason why the narrative is
hey
um we're killing the planet and we
should be worried about that as opposed
to hey we're killing ourselves which by
the way some people do say that but but
the overall narrative but I think the
reason why I think I think the reason
why
I think the reason why is because we
don't we we have taken on a
self-loathing as human beings buddy I
just
run like literally people
desire for annihilation but it's not
even just a desire to want to die it's
it's a loathing of self and it's and and
it's and it you see it in the way that
people don't love each other at all yes
that we are completely polarized or
there's or theirselves for sure but the
way that we are polarized we don't we
see the way that a lot of actually
environmentalists have heard this
argument of like we're a disease humans
are a disease we're this parasite of the
earth well kind of but I I like to me I
go wow that's a really I think that's a
really horrible way to view humanity and
not that Humanity hasn't done some
stupid [__] [__] along the way but
we're also pretty amazing we're this in
I don't know how exactly we evolved into
what we are you can say it was God's
touch you can say it's stoned ape I
think it's probably somewhere in between
I do believe in a Consciousness God was
the dealer was that stone Dave but God
was the weed dealer yeah totally yeah
yeah whatever you know like like you
know divinely uh guided evolution of
some kind whatever the [__] it is but we
are still nonetheless however we got
here were these insane animals that
creatures we are there is no other
creature on earth even very intelligent
ones that deal with the level of anxiety
and stress and depression and all of the
ways we are disconnected from ourselves
each other and yeah and the planet
they're all still kind of doing actual
life yeah where they're either in their
parasympathetic nervous system and
they're chilling and living and eating
and [__] and [__] and doing
whatever animals do animals at large and
then we are the only animal that lives
now by the way now more than ever in the
sympathetic nervous system where we are
constantly in survival mode and I think
that just has to do with the fact that
survival used to be the you know five
like basic pillars of survival you need
to have food water clothing shelter and
tribe those the only things you even
needed to worry about there were no
other worries now granted some of those
things were big worries depending on the
season of the year or whatever can we
find water can we find food but now
we're all I these are my theories but I
think we are all constantly jacked into
the sympathetic nervous system our
survival mode because survival went from
just finding those things to finding one
thing but getting it over and over and
over and over and over again which is
money money replaced all these other
things if you just have this one thing
you can buy all those other things
but if you have a little bit more than
that thing then you can have all this
other [__] as well and then I'll be
happier going back to exactly what we're
talking about right so this Pursuit Of
Constant dopamine happiness yes has made
us all slaves to our sympathetic nervous
system in our fight or flight which
makes us all way more unhappy and stuck
in the stress and anxiety and depression
I was just going to say the the studies
that show that the higher your income
the more likely you are to kill yourself
no [__] or at least be depressed yeah
sure yeah yeah and suicide goes up the
the study that I'm specifically
referencing is uh Mexican families that
uh immigrate from Mexico and start
sending money back so same people they
were working in Mexico then they come to
the states and start working making more
money sending it back those people are
like I'm gonna make up this part but
it's like five times more likely to be
depressed five times more likely to kill
themselves right other sorts of things
because it's funny the more money you
have you just you just said the the
central mythology of our of our culture
is you'll be set yeah when really tribe
if you're depressed where where was I oh
uh in the movie Stutz he was like if
you're depressed even if you go to lunch
with someone you don't like you'll
benefit like any like we think it has to
be like oh I better get Zach Levi yes
you're clearly a genius and hilarious
yeah I do get a lot out of this but I
also get a lot of uh just talking to
somebody at a coffee shop
but the more money you have uh my
YouTube figured out I like I used to I
don't do it anymore but I would watch
tours of houses like a 50 million dollar
house oh sure yeah just because a lot of
styles are the Rich and Famous basically
but now it's a YouTube channel
I don't recommend it I find it deeply
depressing because no wonder somebody
spends 50 million dollars to live in
basically a planet alone yeah and now
you're Sam Rockwell and Moon yes and you
are yes completely cut off your food is
prepared by somebody who doesn't love
you your lawn is cut by someone who
doesn't love you even your friends this
is the risk I I run as a pro as a very
rarefied air comedian person I run this
risk I am friends with my assistant I
love my assistant but I have to make
sure I can't be Tony Stark do you
understand yeah yeah
you need community that we are
evolutionarily built for it we are not
human beings are not lone wolves we we
do not operate in that way we were never
intended to operate in them yeah the
clue is that we're not wolves no and
that's the bottom line Thanks for tuning
in guys my TED Talk
um but no the you should this is this is
one of the I well maybe one day I don't
I don't know what the [__] I'd talk
about but maybe I'll talk about
something I have a theory they're all
CGI no one's ever given a TED Talk
I said it's not real or they're just
really good animatronics like yeah
Disney's really outdone himself yeah
um Hall of president but but it is this
it is this really sad truth which is
you know we it's why people who live in
rural you know tribal peoples in Africa
or or Latin America or whatever uh or or
or Asia or wherever these rural tribal
peoples are that have very little but
are so happy yeah because they never
actually believed or had the opportunity
to believe in the I won't say American
Smith the Western dream which is a myth
the Western it is a myth it is a lie for
the pit of Hell which is if you live in
the right house in the right
neighborhood and have the right income
and you have the right spouse that has
the right job and you have the right
amount of kids to go to the right
schools and they have the right friends
and you have the right amount of cars
and toys and all that stuff then finally
you'll be happy and that is a Lie from
the pit of [__] hell and we all need
to go back to far more minimalistic
lives we do we need to do that take our
money and go build communities don't
build [__] mansions that separate all
of ourselves why do we all need our own
pool we don't why do we all need our own
massive backyard we don't we can share
these grounds pounds we can share these
things and we are happier when we do my
street five houses five lawn mowers
what's going on here yes yeah yeah five
houses five pools yeah five houses uh
ten cars yeah yeah it is true insanity
but there is there is something to what
you're saying obviously is that this was
manufactured I don't want to say we're
victims of it but we were inducted into
a thought system that we're not aware
that we're even adhering to I 100 I
think this goes down to everything I I
don't want to be too preachy against
alcohol but there's a lot of things that
if you trace it back you go like oh this
is just someone selling you something
everything food uh entertainment yeah uh
a new idea a new car a buzz yeah but
like the genius of it and I'm just gonna
put this to you yo Jukebox come on the
genius of it is that you you
sell slavery and you call it freedom do
you see what I'm saying I'm going to
make you dependent on uh sugar alcohol
uh consumerism whatever it might be and
I'm actually going to tell you that your
ability to choose the the things I'm
selling is your personal freedom yeah
where's the the opposite is true freedom
is recognizing that you in this moment
Zach right now assuming we've both had
breakfast we're and you don't need to
use the bathroom or whatever it might be
what what this is the my favorite Cohen
it's not a really Cohen What In This
Moment is lacking but you ask people
that they don't they don't get it no one
understands that come on the truth is
nothing let me put it this way Byron
Katie in her book says the thought that
kicks you out of Heaven you're sitting
on this couch with me yeah you're having
a great time yeah
and we're and we're safe and we're we're
here yeah and we can settle we have the
luxury of settling in to the fact that
we are on a pale blue dot and we could
be hit by meteors but we're not being
hit by meteors right now and
everything's okay yeah
the thought that kicks you out of Heaven
as she puts it is be nice if I had a
coffee right kicks you out yeah totally
so we've taken that whole thing yeah
manipulated it
exaggerated it and then I but the do you
understand my point that the real devil
of it yes is that I say we've been
programmed to believe that we need
meeting me is your freedom yes if I tell
you to stop drinking you say [__] you
this is America yeah and I go I I know
how people like alcohol I enjoyed
alcohol for a long time please don't
think I'm I'm being negative but you
could put in whatever you want there
listen new car sugary snack 100 salty
snack 100 coffee whatever you want but
then you go my freedom is my ability to
choose the thing that's being sold to me
yeah [__] you freedom is recognizing the
the that you don't need those things you
don't need anything you don't ultimately
at the end of the day happy for no
reason exactly exactly happy because you
are a member in we're talking about your
parasympathetic nervous system yeah my
cat has I don't have a cat that helps I
I have your imaginary cat I think of my
cat when I was growing up but it it it
it like you oh they're water yeah sleep
food so good and we can get into that
place the genius and the interesting
thing about a human mind is it can go in
all these other places but I think what
we're saying is it's interesting that
our culture has pushed us into those
other places for profit well but that's
the thing because what started as us
trying to using our our very cool human
brains that we have to problem solve to
problem solve the the the issues of uh
uh survival right these these five
pillars okay well check it out check it
out we can all collaborate we can work
together we start getting into the
Agricultural Revolution whatever it is
now I don't have to worry about food
because Bob's doing the food Bob's on
the food and and and and Barbara's on
the um building some shelter and Tom's
over there figuring out the the waters
you know so so now we all have these
different tasks and we don't have to
work but now that means we went from
Barter and then we were like okay well
now civilization's getting a little bit
bigger so it's not about barter anymore
also I can't be carrying around all of
these supplies to build homes so it's
got to be let's use these shelves and
then we use these shells and that
becomes our currency to just track all
that stuff and then we start becoming
addicted to the Shell we want more
shells because more shells means again
it's our it's our own survival Instinct
playing against us it's our survival
Instinct saying you know you need this
you need these you want these this is
good for you and people figure it out
along the way that they can hijack that
even if they didn't it's not even
intentional but it's like oh well I can
Market I can sell right and what
marketing marketing and sales what
started as a much more I believe you
know and not innocuous but a much more
kind of like uh uh um uh innocent
Pursuit perhaps it was more just like
hey you know we have a good product and
we want to make sure people know about
it and you know whatever well then you
know we get into the [__]
50 the the Mad Men era really right we
start getting well even before that you
know Hearst and all these are doing this
kind of stuff but it just you can track
it you can see it how all of it just
starts becoming far more manipulative
and more manipulative and more
manipulative status and all and then
what you have is what you are yeah and
it's and talk about toddlers uh some of
our parenting books would say like if
you take something from Leela it's like
someone is taking her from me like her
dad oh yeah we are we can Bond like
Wilson I always reference Wilson yeah
yeah we can Bond so hard so much that
our identity is is actually poured yeah
and what for I just love it or or
perhaps it's poured into us you know of
course it becomes a part of our
receptacles I fall into this all the
time neither of us I don't think would
say we're I'm certainly not immune I'm
like should I get the new iPhone yeah
has that eyebrow yeah and and then I
catch myself when my phone is chunkier
it's slowing down
I know it is of course it is and but
this is this is the thing this is what
I'm saying the the designed or planned
obsolescence if you're really watching
it and and if you're a person that has
the means to upgrade their phone yeah
you kind of like it yeah well it becomes
an excuse I'm saying deep deep down I
mean deep I don't know I I I know I know
the point that you're making and I and I
would say perhaps because you get the
new shiny thing yeah you go maybe it's
gonna work but for me though
I would be far happier to be to stop at
a spot and not feel like I'm being
manipulated like because authenticity
authenticity authenticity authentic if
we lived in a far more honest authentic
world even where people are selling or
something but it's like yeah yeah these
are these are bad for you boost is not
good for you I wouldn't it be amazing if
booze companies actually like Hey listen
guys it's just really not good for you
but it makes you [__] feel good and
fun and you can kind of loosen up and
you do what you do right but we're not
by no means should you actually be doing
a lot of this this is not good for you I
mean do you listen to Andrew huberman uh
his podcast just thinking about it oh
man he did recent podcasts about
nicotine cannabis and booze and they
were so eye-opening yeah but booze
especially and actually it shouldn't
even be eye-opening because deep down we
all know it's bad for us we all know
it's a poison but it is nothing but
poison other than a social lubricant you
just said my point though I'm I'm with
you of course I would like to buy an
iPhone we always reference this book
it's called existential Kink it's how
the things you hate you secretly love
them like we have this massive case
texture tendency and I've gotten more in
touch with that meaning someone screws
me over or upsets me or does the wrong
thing if I'm really caught careful or
deliberate I can find an underbelly
where it's like you know tonguing the
part of your gums that are sore like you
like it
talks about that too in our shadow self
I mean you know that that we don't like
in other people is really just a
reflection of what you don't like in
yourself which is I think tying into
that sure you are you don't like this
thing but you like that you don't like
it because or or not that you like that
you don't like it but it's I think it's
kind of somewhat tied to that same kind
of nature in us we're sure we're liking
it because we still need to somehow live
with ourselves I think you might be
making a different point that I also
agree with which is because I was upset
with somebody this morning on the way I
just got some news just kind of
financial news it wasn't that big of a
deal yeah but I caught myself getting
really excited at how mad I was or I
felt it under here it was bubbling yeah
and I was like it wants to come out and
I was like what is that and it was
exactly what you're saying which is if
this person's guilty I'm innocent and I
love that that's that's how projection
Works in my life yeah is I can't wait to
be like you [__] me and it's not gonna
happen I'm not going to do it because I
recognize that I'm the insane person and
I just can't wait to yell at my own
guilt like every every accusation I have
for them you're thoughtless or you're
inconsiderate those are all things that
I'm afraid yeah that we all are afraid
that we are and what I'm saying and we
are sometimes of course you know
everybody is for sure but the quote Oh
sorry you were going to say I would just
to stick the landing when I noticed that
my phone is getting slodgy
and I I am mad that my phone should work
there's another part of me that is more
embarrassing and I don't like that I
have this but again I think it's a
conditioned thing as I go like now I
have an excuse to get the new one 100
it's the excuse yeah and 100 I think
that's why it works and that's why
Instagram ads work because they're like
don't you like that it's personalized
and you're like yeah I kind of do yeah
except that they are obviously listening
to us even though they say they're not
this is I I understand how they're not
how these ads can even end up on my
Instagram yeah when because they say
well for what pyramid pokers you can
poke a pyramid you can yeah buy now
um yeah no I mean there's no they say
it's like no what it is it's like it's
this the way the AI algorithm Works
where if you're around other people
they're looking through they're funny
sounds like what the [__] no not at all
somehow we were talking about you know
inflatable hammocks I nobody I was
talking to before that was looking for
inflatable hammocks I wasn't looking for
inflatable hammers nobody at all and
then five minutes later yeah inflatable
having they're not listening to us [__]
that [__] they are listening to us guys
they are listening to us but I think
we're we're just even this conversation
one step closer to my kids my kids kids
whatever may be going who cares
oh no we're there bro yeah we're not
it's not even your kids most of our
society if we actually cared we'd all be
revolting right now yeah this is really
terrifying Black Mirror [__] this is
1984 Brave New World [__] yeah we are a
lot we are watching it happen in front
of our faces and yet we're all so numb
sucking on the teat of all of this [__]
that we're just we're we're we're so mad
we're so much out we we with all of it
you're back to your original point if
like so
um trust and integrity or reputation are
all attributes that don't really matter
as much as long as you can make money
yes well as long as you can make money
and as long as you can have status and
as long as cool man cool is cancer cool
used to be what cool is supposed to be
which is cool Under Pressure like like
The Fawns you know like cool Henry
Winkler 100 you the cool as it used to
be as a word as a concept was the idea
that you're cool Under Pressure that
like like you're you know you're
unflappable that you're not that it
doesn't mean you're not hot hot is like
okay what's up guys like cool is like
Denzel like be cool well I guess but
again that's to me that's the same thing
it's unflappable yeah yeah but now cool
is what do you wear
what what car do you drive yeah like oh
no no
I'm just kidding and that she was all
over our Instagram all and our all
social media website nobody saw it
except for everyone
um it's all over everywhere and we all
still [__] give into it we all still
want to somehow not look uncool and
that's how they've got us they got us by
the balls bro and we're not doing what
you were saying before which is really
just like the core tenant of Buddhism
which is just to not be in a state of
Desire one way or the other don't desire
that you have more and don't desire that
you have less don't desire that uh you
want you want the Pain to End and don't
desire that you want the joy to continue
forever just accept where you are right
now and know that that is okay yeah you
are okay right there you don't need that
Pepsi you don't need that [__] new
car you don't need these new clothes you
don't you don't need anything to
actually find a contentedness in and of
yourself but we are running from that at
light speed because that's not cool at
all well it's also not special what
you're saying is I was just I texted
this to myself we don't want God or
Nirvana or Liberation or Heaven even we
don't we want this we want to be special
we want to be unique we either want to
hate or love we want God to hate us or
love us but we don't want to merge with
Oneness because you're not there anymore
you know what I'm saying you're saying
like oh just realize that you're
depending on one's view of what Oneness
is but yeah yeah I think to most people
the idea of what that would be was me
would mean that you know that yeah but
the wear of mine where's my specialness
whereas therefore my value but I think
that I think that it's a I don't know I
mean I believe that we are all
infinitely valuable and all entirely
unimportant and the sooner we can
recognize that the sooner we can all be
living a much better life I completely
agree but to go to go into what we were
saying it's like
we'd rather
be buying the clothes and the fighting
for the specialness and the fighting for
the coolness
then recognizing I say this almost every
podcast but the great way is not
difficult for those who have no
preferences and recognizing that you
don't need anything in fact you need to
wake up to your your addiction to need
yeah and and to and to lose that desire
one of my favorite Buddhist things is
why am I happy I'm happy because I know
this couch is already broken it's
already dust it's already gone the
mountains have already been leveled it's
all impermanent so you recognize that
yeah but what I want I think the first
step to merging with truth is
recognizing that you deep down back to
the unconscious phone desires you don't
actually want it because nobody taught
you to want it so you don't actually
want what the phone the Oblivion of
perfect love and Oneness well this is a
problem I mean no doubt I mean you know
so much of what I talk about it you'd
like to be in the Oblivion of perfect
love and Oneness if you could sell it to
someone else you know what I'm saying
like we don't have a lot of good
examples there are some sorry right
what you're saying is which is which is
that well in a sense
you're you are absolutely right we don't
know we don't have an example we don't
have examples we don't have enough
examples we don't have enough that is
pointing us toward the beauty that is
compassion the beauty that is empathy
the beauty that is kindness the beauty
is that is patience the beauty that is
actual love and I'm not talking about
the feeling of love I'm talking about
um one of my one of my favorite quotes
which is I believe it's Thomas Aquinas
but it goes all the way back to
Aristotle which is love is to will the
good of the other it does not mean that
I feel lovey-dovey for this person
that's the feeling of feeling in love
perhaps but that's a feeling you the the
love that is love is a choice and it's
the you know that we don't see we don't
have not been taught the beauty of what
any of these things are because they're
so antithetical to all the [__] that
were being sold all the [__] time all
the time and unfortunately that all
starts in the home as well because if we
don't have parents and by the way almost
none of us really did I mean I would say
the vast majority of people did not have
parents that really understood what it
meant to love themselves so how could
they possibly model or show their
children how to love themselves not that
it's not not that it hasn't happened not
that there aren't some [__] unicorn
parents out there but by and large you
know it just wasn't societal for a long
long long long long long time I think
people like Jesus were were trying to
say these types of things like can we
actually love each other what does it
mean to love your enemy and pray for
your persecutor like that kind of [__]
that's real love but uh but that's why I
was so crazy nobody believed that [__]
you were like oh you're a Samaritan [__]
you you can die you know like they were
we were all just you know just split up
and bifurcated to left to right and
center and all that just trailed with us
into modern society even if we're all
like a Melting Pot in the U.S
we still our parents still never learned
generationally to love themselves well
that's what we're saying that I'm
completely agreeing and I I really enjoy
your brain
[Laughter]
I hate us a Samaritan
I exist this is what I'm saying yes when
you love you start to vanish when you
forgive when you are Mercy I'm not even
forgiving you let's say you did me dirt
yeah yeah and I forgive you that's
that's cheap [__] that sucks because I'm
acknowledging that you did it Mercy is
just like you didn't do anything because
nothing's it's all it's all meaning the
ego is never gonna like it it's it's
it's a complete dissolving into perfect
love loving lovingness yes but you
vanish when that happens Jesus vanished
Jesus vanished he was here but he wasn't
here in the way that we're here because
the way that we're here is by judging
yeah demarcating judging ourselves and
judging and judging others yes exactly
based on completely subjective ideas of
what we're thought you and I are hanging
out and going like what is his
definition of love I'm not saying it's
bad but this is how you are oh not at
all no I know but no hear me hear me now
call me now I mean I don't understand me
later that's what I was looking for I'm
not even saying we're just I'm saying
you and I right now are defining our
identity bouncing off of one another
because that's what it is sure I don't
think that's what Jesus did I don't
think Jesus was interested in going like
where are you and where am I and where
do I fit because love is this goes back
to my thing we don't want it because you
you're not there anymore you could say
you're just a vessel of I think the love
I I would say though and maybe this is
just the
I don't know the The Optimist in me or
whatever but I actually do think deep
deep deep deep down at the core core
like the chorus of course
is our soul
that
may have even you know depending on what
you believe you know come and
reincarnated this could be multiple like
whatever it is but
home like you know because I do think
home is is whatever that other place is
like ramdas says we're all just walking
each other home so that means we started
there we're gonna go back there and
whether you know if you're in the
judeo-christian you know Muslim kind of
tree that's the end and you're back home
or if you're in the other type of tree
where there's reincarnated energy that
means you're still going back to home
whatever home base is you know what I
mean and I think that we all want deep
down deep deep down we all actually want
that and we know what it feels like
because that is where all the love is
that's where it's all that Source energy
and love is all generated and so we want
it we just we come back into these flesh
bags these meat bags and that perhaps
even is like kind of what again and I
know you understand these types of
things uh you know where biblically
you're talking about like the you know
the Flesh and the spirit and all that
jazz like the spirit is our soul is is
still remembering or is connected to
whatever home is and these meat bags
that we get thrown into have these more
kind of by the way and I don't think all
like all these are horrible sinful
things or whatever but uh but though but
they are more deceived by the ego they
are more deceived by survival because
these need to survive our soul actually
doesn't need to survive when I'm saying
you don't want perfect Oneness I mean
your ego
shirt and by the way this is a fun
Christian fact that you can carry in
your back pocket it's a fun one is that
when Paul wrote about the flash he
actually that was his word for the ego
so when we talk about well my spirit's
so hungry but my flesh is weak yeah yeah
we thought it meant my ding dong I can't
stop [__] it means it it meant what
we would say in modern spirits well I've
always kind of believed that let me say
parlance parlance parlance let me say
parlance okay yeah that's it so I'm
agreeing with you
buddy just CE what you're saying
are we going home are you ready to bake
your noodle that's bacon noodle if time
is an illusion which even our Quantum
friendship totally we are home we could
call that we could call that heaven we
could call that Oneness we could call it
the Dow we could call it Nirvana sure
it's all happening at once so we didn't
go anywhere
what's in the way of us recognizing that
is our specialness is our ego is our
differentiation our judgments and our
lack of forgiveness so our job here is
to I would say is to use this dream or
this dance or this play for me to
forgive you whatever it might be me to
love you me to extend Mercy to you me to
feed you me to love you me to be kind to
you because in doing that to you I'm
Wrecking I'm getting rid of my guilt and
my blindness that nothing has happened
if God is one if it's all one I'm part
of that Oneness and all this guilt sin
fear all that stuff is an illusion and
you and I become vehicles to remember
that to remember to become a member yeah
yeah dude let's do some cook
oh you haven't already I thought you
were doing it yeah I know you seem like
you've been on like at least three bumps
I would like to see what happens if you
drank that magic mind I gave you don't
do it
no that's water the little guy what's
the little guy that's magic mine I
wonder what is Magic mind I'll tell you
well okay it's it's I drink it right now
yeah you should shake it off it's it's
matcha
so it's adaptogens you know adaptogens
are yeah to help you cope with stress
nootropics help you think and a little
bit of caffeine from matcha and it's
[__] dope and it tastes great too uh
speaking they are a sponsored but
they're sponsored because I love them oh
yeah yeah you understand started that
way what if you hate it
but that seems like you brought that in
I I'll give you a case it's great for
performing if you're unset and all that
oh great when you're saying great well
listen I need I'm I'm not supposed to be
drinking uh coffee right now because
coffee is that's it yeah yeah so this is
where you'll totally take this as an
alternative the whole thing is Magic
mine
say magicmine.com weird uh
um we'll be right back speaking all this
capitalist DACA and then I was like we
gotta pay Katie Somebody's gotta pay
Katie we'll be back in uh three minutes
two three minutes and we'll get more
into this it's gonna be it's it's gonna
be great it's gonna be great
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at mism
and Maine the makers of the best most
incredible performance fabric dress
shirts and frankly just the best dress
shirts I've discovered in years as a
touring stand-up comedian I'm constantly
looking for clothes that are comfortable
enough to fly in but will also look good
when I get on stage because often I'm
traveling the same day I'm performing I
want to be able to get off the plane
look great feel comfortable on the plane
and then go on stage and feel confident
and great about what I'm wearing and
missing in Maine has put an end to these
terrible scratchy ill-fitting dress
shirts that I was just not excited about
and they've made not only the best
looking dress shirts for real for real
but the best feeling it's always about
the material frankly I haven't even
really been a big fan of dress shirts
until I found mizen and May game because
I hadn't found one that fit just right
looked just right and the material on
the outside everything about it feels
perfect the fit the look and the feel of
the material all three Nissan and Main
that's why you got to check them out
they are the inventors of the
performance fabric dress shirt there's
nothing worse than being uncomfortable
and missing in Maine is here to help
that is why they make the most
lightweight breathable and moisture
wicking dress shirt on Earth I can say
because I perform in these shirts they
absolutely are moisture wicking and that
is super super important for me they're
high performance dress shirts warm in
the winter cool in the summer keep me
warm on the airplane too which is super
important think of this clothing as your
secret weapon for any occasion I'm
confident if you give mizen and Main a
try you'll never go back to Conventional
men's clothing again this is definitely
one of those companies that when I
started using them and we got the promo
code I've been using my own promo code
to re-up because they are actually the
best dress shirts I've ever worn it's a
fabric I've never felt like it I've
never felt a fabric like this before and
here's the best part one of the best
parts I would say the fit and feel and
the fabric is the best part but one of
the other best boards is that they are
completely machine washable that means
no more expensive trips to the dry
cleaner and for the cold weather they've
got amazing flannels pants sweaters and
jackets made from that same is in the
main material that they have become
famous for so even if you aren't a dress
shirt person they've got clothing you
need to feel to believe so if you want
the best cold weather clothing this
holiday season check out mizzen and Main
right now go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com and use
promo code weird to get 25 off any
regular price order of 130 bucks or more
that's 25 off when you go to mizzen and
main.com and use promo code
weird hot cold casual formal they've got
you covered you're gonna love it check
it out for real missing and main.com and
use promo code weird to show your
support of the show all right back to
the app
we're back and we're back
oh man podcasts are great
um going back so really quickly though
going to what you're talking about about
how please it's all happening
concurrently right yes so
which means this is a dream which was
totally a great dream uh fever dream
well a great fever dream um but no you
know I totally like I was sitting there
not too long ago actually you know as
I've as I've kind of pulled at various
threads within my own kind of you know
spirituality and and walk with God and
stuff and you know I can't remember who
it was I think it was
Stephen Fry maybe
um although he was making an argument
that I'd heard before throughout my life
and always had a hard time reconciling
which was how can God be both
all-powerful
and all benevolent if so many of these
horrible things are going on in the
world that people you know kids are born
with cancer or car accidents or Wars or
earthquakes or whatever the [__] is
going on and I remember kind of you know
growing up within my
whatever my version of Christianity was
I know I was always like I don't
understand like that's a really great
argument and I don't know how to
reconcile this and you know
unfortunately most
Christian leaders I find God bless them
they their their their hearts may be in
great places but they haven't done the
the mental gymnastics to figure that out
and so it's always like well
it's a mystery well it's a mystery I'm
like I don't think that God and if in
fact there is this God that we're all
talking about I don't think that God
operates in this way I think actually
there's a lot more logic behind all of
it if we really want to do the work to
figure out how how does all this Matrix
works you know how the Matrix works and
how how what how is it scaffolding and
how does it all go
which again the more we dive into
Quantum and all this kind of stuff
they're seeing these incredible kind of
you know uh uh
um blueprints of various things and how
you know things are and how they don't
work but anyway
so the I I hear this argument throughout
my life and I'm like this is a really
good argument and I don't know how to
reconcile this until I actually allowed
my kind of nerd
comic book reading brain
to get just a little outside the boxing
creative and I go oh wait a minute no no
no no of course he he it whatever God
is in fact all-powerful and I believe
all good in that all good resides within
the entity or the energy that is God one
might also argue that all darkness is a
part of that too and there's The Duality
and whatever but point is
um
I was able to finally reconcile it in
that oh yes there is clearly a an
infinite Multiverse and there always has
been because if God if we all agree if
Christians believe there's this God and
this God is all-powerful and operates
outside of space and time well guess
what that means god is seeing every
possible variation of your life and my
life and everyone else's life and every
version of this Earth that existed and
didn't exist the the the star matter
that created this galaxy or didn't
create this galaxy all of those infinite
possibilities have all happened which
means there's this incredible Justice in
it all because those kids that that are
born with cancer and die there's other
timelines where they were president of
the United States or the world or
whatever there were versions of it where
we died of cancer there were versions
where we didn't get born at all we've
never existed all of that is going on it
simultaneously and to your point
therefore also is all of this home of
this other place it's all happening in
this space interesting yeah I mean again
theoretically but
one of the few guests that was like
taking a stab at something like that I
don't mean to take a stab like that one
right that was great yeah thanks my
friend Michael younger in his book it's
called this it's a great book and a
great title for a book this yeah great
yeah uh especially because it's about
non-duality but he goes if you were
Infinity what game wouldn't you play
um so I know it's weird to think of all
of these horrible things as games but
like no but but I but I but but I but I
absolutely understand I absolutely don't
understand what you're saying I
absolutely understand what you're saying
because I think that we unfortunately
again through a lot of religion we have
applied
our humanness to God in in these very
strange ways what's it yep and if you
are an infinite being that by the way
that is all as well like God God is such
a force of Star Wars God is in and
through all things God suffers with us
like when we're like where is God when
this terrible thing is happening yeah
God is the thing that the terrible thing
is happening to and the person that's
mourning the terrible thing meaning God
suffers with us through us and as us so
that's and and the thing that at the
very least allows the terrible thing to
happen if not also is the terrible thing
yeah that's right which is even more
complex and crazy but again who the [__]
are we to question this thing that we
agree or again if you agree there is a
God which
you know there are more theists than
than atheists and if you were a theist I
mean literally it's kind of like God 101
if you believe in the concept of a God
that means you're believing in this
concept of an infinite being on some
level which means who the [__] are you
to even start questioning what it's uh
morals or its motives or its character
or anything else like the way we the
most arrogant thing that human beings I
think have almost ever said in the
history of human beings is I know
there's a God and I know it completely
yeah like what the [__] right you are
this infinitely teeny little speck of a
nothing how could you possibly think
that you knew all that is an infinite
thing like the the hubris but it's also
the hubris is what's killing us all the
time this is the thing that's [__] us
all up all the time right it's very
interesting I have a couple things to
throw your way one is um loving this
conversation
father Greg Boyle said this to me but
I'm trying to remember who said it
originally because he was quoting
somebody I have it in my email
but he says uh God protects me from
nothing but sustains me through
everything I think is a very oh yeah one
thing to say yeah because a lot of
people especially when we become
atheists and as I did it's usually
because of some let down insecurity sure
someone broke into the property
something happened that you didn't want
and you go well where is this when you
say all powerful and infinite yeah let's
let's be real we're picturing a person
like us who just can do whatever he
wants yeah like Shazam I work you into
it yeah and also it just exists through
all time when infinite doesn't mean
exist through all time it means it's
Timeless it's completely there is no
time it's the absence of time yeah and
also all powerful this is the one that
I'm gonna do my best to articulate to
you um I'm getting it from A Course in
Miracles I had never heard of a
explanation for these things until I
studied the course which has some
similarities to Hinduism and Buddhism
but here we go uh they would say that
according to the courses theology
that God didn't create this world that's
why it's so [__] up because God is
perfect Oneness
uh we it split into his son I know these
are metaphors yeah yeah when this can't
split but we are that perfect oneness's
son we were with God we had an idea uh
because everything is an idea
that we could be separate from God and
in that instant
we uh created this world that was what
started the Big Bang was an idea of
separateness but once you're separate
god is perfect Oneness this is where it
gets really chunky funky
I won't be able to answer all your
questions I'm just letting you know I'm
not an expert in this in this uh
metaphysics the idea
God doesn't know about this world
meaning this is a puppet show and the
only thing God is interested in isn't
what happens to the puppets it's
changing the Puppeteer it's waking your
mind your soul your witness to the
reality that the separation couldn't
happen that we are still with God that
we are in heaven that or whatever or
perfect Oneness right right this is
where it no no
and this stuff is just a passing show
and it's not the point so we shouldn't
pray to God to help me have a good
conversation with Zach or to find a
parking spot or to save me from this
that or the other we should only pray to
God to change our mind and by mind I
mean the Buddhist mind capital M mind uh
you could call it your soul your spirit
yeah have that make a different choice
because right now it's so seduced by the
UPS the Downs the lefts the rights the
angry the Judgment the vitriol the
violence the hate all of it it it's too
seductive so we stay here and we need to
go wait I've made not an it's not a
sinful choice there's no error nobody's
mad right right but we're actually
hiding from God here we made a place
projected by our own guilt to hide from
God because we think because we
separated from him we killed him because
here we are in a world of Duality so how
could perfect Oneness exist if you and I
are having a dualistic experience so we
killed God he's mad at us he's coming to
get us like I Know What You Did Last
Summer
and even if you've been angry half dead
fisherman and no matter how many times
you hit him with your car he's still
going to come back like a zombie and
kill you so we live in fear and would
rather play this game over and over and
over and that's and this is again this
is their thought system over and over
and over because we can't we're afraid
we're afraid of going home so you need
to forgive one another forgive
yourselves wake up that there's been no
error and then you and then you then you
return to where you already are and the
separation never happened that's my
that's the best I can do at summarizing
it I mean listen I try track all that I
track all that I couldn't see you
getting it I was like you're a rare bird
man there's a lot of people on this
podcast I'm not saying they glaze over
no no no no no no listen you know my I
have one of my great weaknesses is that
I literally do not read enough like I'm
so impressed with people like yourself
who are so well read and and genuinely I
really am it's one of it's one of the
things I I'm trying to get better at I
struggle with but
even though I haven't read as much as on
tape at all yeah well still even still
you know I've I actually almost have a
harder time listening to a book because
it's I'm more easily distracted there
you go visually yeah you know I'll I'll
just I'll be listening but then I'm
something is distracting me visually
yeah and then my brain's going in a
million places as opposed to if I'm have
a visual stimulus granted I just paid
you know words on a page but at least
that kind of keeps me locked in a little
bit anyway this might be why we love
comic books
um but but anyway point is I don't read
enough but I spend a lot of time
thinking I always have yeah I I I I want
because I want to know what's real I
want to know what's really real I don't
want to just believe some [__] that
my parents taught me or anybody else
taught me or whatever you said that
earlier sorry keep going yeah yeah I
that that all of these thought systems
of Course in Miracles Buddhism Hinduism
even uh mystical Christianity would say
there's a part of your awareness not
your brain yeah but the witnessing the
thing that's watching your brain yeah
that you call I yeah yeah yeah yeah we
are not the voice of our mind we are the
one who hears it that's right yeah yeah
from the untethered Soul which I haven't
read
who needs it you just summarized it but
that witnessing presence that's in all
of us yeah does remember perfect Oneness
and does remember God so what you're
saying I don't want to read it I don't
want I want to experience it that's
mysticism well it's not that I don't
want to read it though it's that I just
genuinely struggle with reading but you
want to read it so you can experience it
I wonder if you are it sounds like you
are I'm experiencing it but I I think
that one of the beautiful things about
reading is that particularly if you're
reading other people who are are
enlightened or who have had you know
um really interesting and cool
experiences in their experiencing of it
they're able to put things into words
that perhaps you haven't been able to
really figure out yet yeah and that's
why I wish I read I read more because I
I would like I don't think there's a
problem anyway anyway
um can I say this you sound like the
people I talk to who read a lot well all
right so who cares good
I'm tracking all that you said I I can I
can I can see where that our argument
whatever you know how whatever is
another story perspective yeah exactly
um but I would say though the thing that
I I guess the first thing that comes to
mind and that that I would my big
question is well then in that it's kind
of you're operating under the the
pretense that we humans and Earth are
the only
existence of something that would be
life outside of right so like in that
scenario we wanted to be more we got
splintered off we splinted ourselves off
God still knows we're all still a part
of it but we did this but I'm I'm of the
belief that in this massive Universe
there are probably other planets that
are populated by some kind of other life
which means well then what the [__] did
they do maybe they did the same thing
simultaneously maybe they did at a
different time but if it all goes back
to the Big Bang it would have all had to
happen kind of in that moment for sure
you know but I don't know again this is
just you know unpacking and thinking
about things love need yeah I would say
this thought system would say that uh
the the Oneness that we were was like a
pane of glass and it broke and it's
splintered and every piece of glass
chemically biochemical or whatever you
want to say is still glass but it's it's
the shattered pieces of God's one son is
what they would say including all those
other aliens including every microbe in
your body is also acting out just saying
yes thing 100
is all life in my opinion God God is
like again like the force in Star Wars
like the mitochondria like in and
through all things yes it is all even
the things that maybe aren't alive as
well I mean I gotta believe that all
matter is still God all all time space
you you might like uh Rupert Spira too
that's how I got warmed up to the course
he not not that he's he is enough in
himself but he whatever it took me out
he was the amuse Bush I would never call
Rupert spider but I bet he'd love it he
would say that all of this is like so
our experience of this couch
we we think that the scientific model is
that objective reality exists right and
we participate with it through our
Consciousness most mystical thought
systems are would say as as Rupert
explains it they are Consciousness
meaning there's nothing to seeing except
the part of me that knows what I'm
seeing so seeing is knowing hearing is
knowing right touching is knowing it all
happened so this this sofa is actually
made of knowing it doesn't exist it is
in the same exact way that a dream is
made you make every aspect of the dream
that's that a lot of the yeah and by the
way there's science there's there's
hardcore quantum physics are saying the
same thing they're saying this like this
doesn't exist unless we're looking at it
which that's what I'm saying really hard
knowing yeah but and by the way which
may be the case but I man that's where
I'm my noodle gets really cooked because
that means we all three of us have to be
having the same dream in order for these
to exist in the same time in the same
if there's only one mind and and I
really think if you trace that back sure
what else could there be but yeah but
one but that's why I like the the dream
thing last night I had a dream and I was
hanging out with some people and we were
talking and I was touching and I was
seeing and I was perceiving yeah and I
woke up and I was like oh I was in my
bed I think the same thing is happening
here and and it this is Rupert Spire he
said it when he was nine years old he
said nine nine he goes I was German and
he was saying no I can't be sure but um
he was he's in his 50s or 60s now but he
was saying when he was a little boy he
goes this is God's dream and it's our
job to make it a nice dream and I was
like here's why you make it a nice dream
though if I'm judgeful judgeful
judgmental full of judgment yeah ugly
nasty to you again that's just
projection and that's keeping me in the
dream if I forgive you meaning not even
logically go like well Zach was a piece
of [__] to me today but maybe he was
grumpy [__] that low-grade well vodka
forgiveness yeah I mean Mercy like if I
think Zach is is [__] with me I
believe Zach is a separate thing from me
I think that Oneness is a is a lie and
the ego's reality is the truth and
that's that's a that's sort of a
blasphemy not meaning a guilt not
something to feel bad it's just not true
I I believe that the dream is real all I
need to work on is my Puppeteer not the
puppet show yeah and if if you as a
puppet punch me getting mad at the
puppet is [__] dumb it's the
puppeteers let's fix the puppeteers
truly truly and but I would say though
that you know at least what I've
experienced and one of the things I talk
about in the book is you know there's
there's it's you want to get to radical
love but you've got to start with
radical acceptance then you get to
radical forgiveness which helps you to
get to the radical love but the radical
forgiveness and the acceptance that
stuff you know and and us you know
getting to this place where it's not
just this again this well vodka
forgiveness of like okay I guess I'll
forgive you it's no no it's recognizing
that
anyone who's doing anything punching you
punching someone else starting a [__]
War whatever pick your poison
every single person is still operating
out of their conditioning we are all
products of our environment at the end
of the day I mean you could argue that
there's sociopaths and Psychopaths and
that's a slightly different thing
because it's already like biochemical or
whatever but even that there's still a
product like how can you judge how can
you look at those people even for the
horrendous things that they do Jeffrey
Dahmer whatever you know you go that's
and it doesn't mean you excuse the
things that they do you don't excuse the
puppet punching you in the face it's not
an excuse well that puppet goes to Papa
jail well we just don't buy it we just
go it's it's a puppet show but put that
puppet in jail well oh yeah sure but but
that but even that can be a better
process if we were to actually stop
dehumanizing Yes or depopitizing this is
this is Father Greg he's like it's not
uh evil it's mental illness yeah all of
it it's some version of somebody not
understanding what is actually a more
righteous way of going about doing well
everything is love we're asking For Love
or and a lot of these things that need
to be loved can be mental diagnoses and
the further down we go yeah guilt starts
to become a much more complicated issue
we always reference the sniper in Texas
it's one of the first mass shootings and
he remembers suicide note said you need
to examine my brain I something's wrong
with me and like I'm not I don't want to
be doing this basically yeah they did
they cut them open and he had a tumor in
the part of his brain that controls
sociopathic violent Behavior so was he
guilty question mark is anyone guilty
question mark but here's who doesn't
that what Jesus was talking about
exclamation point yes but here's who
doesn't want that if we're really being
honest there's none righteousness you
don't want Mercy we don't want it we did
this is what I'm saying I know you you
think you do and maybe you and I we want
the Oneness okay we want it the part of
us we all and we're all here trying to
get it and but okay the part of us that
wants it I'm gonna say when I I say we
don't want it right let me be more clear
okay our ego doesn't want it our
separate selves don't want it sure the
memory of God of course wants it but
because it still is it right but I would
I would say that our soul and our ego
are separate I think the ego comes with
the body I think the soul is of the pure
version of what we actually are and so
for my own terminology I would say when
we what we want what the real essence of
we is the soul and what the soul wants
is that the ego and the [__] and the
flesh or you know whatever that is that
doesn't want it because that is the
construct of whatever this particular
simulation is and what survival is and
all of that jazz and by the way and you
can see it and you see it throughout the
rest of the animal kingdom there is no
mercy in the animal kingdom I don't know
if you're familiar with this um
Instagram account called nature is metal
it is fantastic it's something I I I
encourage everyone to go follow just if
nothing else just to have a reminder of
what we are still attached to in the
animal world and it is a lot of [__]
horribleness yeah little bunnies and our
pray our prey animals and little and
wolves are predators and they don't give
two [__] about the the the the bunny or
its family or anything else and by the
way and we don't and none of us hold
them accountable we're like well they're
animals they're they're doing that thing
that's because their instincts their
survival instincts their ego is just
going and going and going we have an
opportunity as human beings with us with
a whatever different type of Soul not to
I think animals all also have their own
versions of souls or whatever that is
maybe they're even the same type of
thing but they're
in us because they're in a different
container they act in a different way
but nonetheless the we the actual we I
think we want it I think we're I think
that is I think that's the end game I
think that like if this is all one cool
big simulation video game and if there
is like a kill screen like to get to the
actual end means we all actually get
everyone to put down our [__] swords
and truly love each other and forgive
each other and that means accepting that
we're all doing our best every one of us
and if we saw somebody go and do a
horrible thing instead of us being
immediately you animal you monster you
[__] piece of [__] which is what we
all want to do because our ego wants to
feel Superior to this person so that we
can survive better and so we go to these
places and we deem them monsters and we
put them in a criminal system that is so
[__] broken and just making them even
more animalistic in their ego and their
drive and their programming that's
getting us farther and farther from the
win it's just bringing us it's not just
farther apart from right now like the
actual long-term win the long-term win
is when we can all actually do this
thing that I again Jesus whomever he was
or whatever all that actually you know
something I've even heard people say
that it was Seneca which is an
interesting Theory but point is that
Jesus was that the emperor I don't think
Senator was was Seneca and Emperor I
don't think he was talking about the
same thing anyway but the point is when
Jesus is talking about to love your
enemy and pray for your persecutor this
is exactly what he's talking about he's
saying how the [__] how can you think
that this people you deem them your
enemy
that you deem them you're persecutor and
they might actually be persecuting you
but they're doing it because they think
what they're doing is right
they're not no no he's been sitting
around spinning their mustache being
like I can't wait to do wrong ah I want
to do wrong right no they think somehow
in their upbringing up in their
programming and how they came into this
world their ego was telling them this is
how you do it this is how you survive
this is whatever you need to do and the
sooner we can all recognize that oh
they're wrong
but it's not because they're evil it's
because they're wrong right and we have
to and it doesn't mean we don't correct
these people we actually still have to
it doesn't mean because people say well
if I just forget if we just do that if
we just forgive people well then they'll
just keep traipsing all over the place
they'll just keep doing these bad things
like no no no no there's a difference
between accept like forgiving and ex and
just like excusing we're not excusing
anything people still need to be
responsible for their actions you can
hold them accountable without saying you
[__] monster instead saying hey hey
you know Ted
I don't know if you know this but you
killed those people
that is 100 not okay and that is very
wrong and you're gonna have to go to
prison because of that but we're going
to do everything we can while you're in
this place to try and help you figure
out why you did that and help us all
understand why because if we all
understand if we all actually care about
the why
we start to solve the problem right but
we don't care about the [__] why we
should go [__] doesn't matter they did
wrong according to whatever hour by the
way totally subjective current societal
Norms are right that is ever shifting
Sands like you know what we think right
now and particularly in like you know
and again this is one of my issues with
at least kind of where woke has gone in
a lot of ways which is like well we got
to cancel all these people from the past
it's like hey guys listen they might not
have been doing things the way we do
things now and thank God we do a lot of
the things we do them the way we do them
now but to think for one second that
they thought they were do they all
thought they were doing the right thing
right all those people were playing by
whatever the rules were of that [__]
time and nobody was sitting around being
like I can't believe it like and who's
not to say that 100 years from now let's
say nobody eats animals anymore and
they're all going to be looking back at
all of our Barbarian asses for eating
animals right now I actually like eating
animals I think it's a great source of
protein probably the best whatever makes
a whole nother conversation but you
understand what I'm saying yeah this is
like sliding scale of morality it's like
what the no stop the sliding scale and
just recognize that we're all no matter
where you're born in the history of
mankind you are doing the best that you
think that you can do with the tools
that were available to you at that
[__] time right and as soon as we can
all rub our header on that idea that's
where we all start going to a better
place but that requires us not wanting
to constantly sit in Judgment of
everyone else which is what we do and by
the way reality television is a perfect
example of that because tell me one
reality television show where the
audience is not judging the people on
the television the entire time it's
either you're judging them because
they're on a competition show they're
singing songs or doing America's Got
Talent whatever it is so you're actually
judging their performance yeah or you're
just judging their character as people
which is why everyone's like well it's
you ask people like why do you watch The
Bachelor why do you watch Keeping Up
with the Kardashians it's a guilty
pleasure it's a guilty pleasure it's
like do you have any any idea how bad
that is like and by the way and again
this isn't me trying to cast this
version or judgments on anyone involved
in that stuff but I do think we all have
to take a really [__] hard long look
at this because it's really just people
sitting around being like these [__]
idiots right am I right oh my God they
think this is love oh my god oh wow I'm
rooting for Kristen because she's a
[__] oh yeah eat that popcorn it's all
just judgment it's all just so you can
feel a little bit better about yourself
at the end of the day and scapegoat sure
same well yeah to me that's all in the
same bucket of course yeah judgment is
scapegoating yeah again A Course in
Miracles really has you watch your
thoughts and all your attack thoughts
and your hate thoughts and I was like oh
my god I've been swimming so deep in
like that person's an idiot because I'm
so afraid that I'm an idiot so I make
them the idiot and as long as they're an
idiot I'm not an idiot because I know
they're an idiot and you're absolutely
right uh reality TV is like running with
weights if you're training in the
Judgment Olympics reality TV is like
running on in a pool yeah you know it's
like it man it's like running it is with
a lot of resistance and you get really
good at it yeah I would say that every
there's a lot of things like that
pornography can change you change your
wires oh it's totally [__] up entire
generations of men particularly men
women too but young men are getting like
super [__] up and what channel yeah
what chance what chance what chance I I
do think we'll see
uh Humanity will adapt you know it's
it's like it's a psychological way of
like life finds a way meaning we'll
either start seeing kids that start
being like this isn't this isn't how
it's supposed to be or meteorites and we
start over but something's gonna yeah
something's gonna happen I mean I
as much as I want every as much as I
want all of us to actually get to this
kill screen and like really all figure
out how to love our love each other king
of kung reference yeah well or Pac-Man
or or yeah the documentary for certainly
I was gonna say that's where most of us
learned about Christmas you get into
Gill screens bro oh no not before no
please I was never that good at these
[__] arcade games
um but yeah I mean as much as I want us
to get to that place there is definitely
a part of me that's like yeah maybe
meteor is just what we need I don't know
I don't know it's it's just so sad
because we're just so [__] right now I
don't think we get anywhere by not by
being unfucked though like going for
Utopia this is this is the hard truth of
spiritual enlightenment Nirvana like
Jesus saying the poor will always be
amongst you it's like fixing the world
I'm not saying we don't do it but the
reason we do it
it's like Father Greg says about Homeboy
Industries he's like it's like are you
helping them he's like they're helping
me in loving ex-gang members and helping
them he's learning to love and forgive
and help himself because there's another
game being played meaning I don't know
if every single ego is going to be like
oh what have I been doing and it's going
to be like It's a Wonderful Life and we
haven't but I know it I know it sounds
like there is a way to pull the plug on
the whole thing though that that maybe
I'm even more naive meaning if we wake
up we'll pull the we won't fix every
problem but we can re remember remember
and go home
but I but while we're here just to agree
with you
yeah hand out some PB and J's and and
help and fix and reform and and protest
and all that I'm not saying not I would
never say don't do anything oh but I
think there's another game going and I
don't think the game is sweep the
streets I don't want it to be yeah I
don't want it to be I I I I want I I
want us to start waking up to actual
love I mean genuine I mean that's that
that's the book I mean and and that's
all I mean the book is about my mental
my own personal mental health journey
and kind of you know slightly memoirish
and that we I talk about the various
things that brought me to that created
most all the trauma in my life and
brought me to my knees and all this
therapy that I went to but at the end of
it all what I learned one of the biggest
lessons I learned was that I didn't love
myself and we don't love ourselves we
can't really love other people as much
as we think that we might be it's that's
not a real whole healthy love that is a
version of love
but if we can really get every problem
that we have in this world man if you
trace it Upstream
every single problem every single thing
that we're all that they're all these
ngos all these non-profits are all
trying to separately fix if we actually
went Upstream
the problem is all right here it's
somebody's broken head and broken heart
that's what it is love or a lack of it
yeah that's what Mr Right yes that's
what Mr Rogers said yeah he said every
problem is solved by love or caused by a
lack of oh man yeah that guy was so he
was CGI I knew it
nobody could be that perfect we can't
get into it the way he fed those fish
was so suspectful it was the same every
time watch a supermarket
it was ones and zeros Fred Rogers was
CGI you heard it here first man I saw
that documentary I cried my eyes out I
cried he was just such a beautiful
wonderful human being and a soul and
like was so ahead of understanding where
all of this [__] was going like just
literally like I loved that he had that
episode where he just sits there and he
goes
we're going to learn what one minute
feels like
and he just sets the clock there
and he turns it on and Leah just sits in
silence for one minute slowing kids
Minds back down again yeah just to be
again to be here right not needing the
next stimuli not needing the next thing
so that and going back to your kid this
one of the craziest like every single
kid how fast they get over one toy yeah
by the way you see it in dogs too I mean
it's not even like it's a very just
animal like a thing in us it's a part of
the ego and survival no it is it's you
get the thing you get the dopamine oh my
God I got the new thing well if we were
designed to be satisfied we'd be dead
because our ancestors I mean real early
I'm going to say it Homo erectus
rexus is running around all erect and he
finds some raspberries and if he was
like I'm good he'd lay down there and
he'd die he's got a he's gotta learn to
store and and and predict sure sure and
all of that sort of stuff so it's I I
think it's all milkshake right so
milkshake tastes good and you want
another milkshake because your human
animal is just not used to getting that
much sugar and fat yeah and sugar and
fat by the way we can poo-poo them all
day but they keep you alive if you and I
and I hope one day this happens are in a
post-apocalyptic future but at least
it's us
and we're walking around we have
machetes and there's kind of like that
ashy snow it looks like snow it's not
snow you can tell it's like it's like St
Louis
yeah it's Fallout and we're walking
around if you find a milkshake that's
the best [__] thing that could happen
for sure it'll keep you alive yeah so
but we're living in a world of infinite
milkshakes and it's the same with
infinite toys infinite entertainment but
it's all there's nothing inherently
wrong with the software that tells you
eat sugar and fat it's just that culture
has uh evolved past the human animal yes
because the salesman the sales of it all
the marketing of it all has now tapped
into and hijacked what that survival
mechanism is that is by the way dopamine
we they have these they've done these
incredible studies they took a rat
and they disabled its ability to create
dopamine everything else was totally
normal chill chill chill
they set the right chill day they set
the rat down something's different they
put a bowl of food next to their rat
and they're at Star to death no matter
how much pain no matter how much
anguish it was going in as it was
literally starving to death the only
reason why you would get up to go and do
the motivator the the the the the the
the motivator the reward hormone is this
dopamine and like you said we needed it
to survive because why the [__] else
would we run 10 miles or more every day
to go hunt and gather why would we do
that Nike just do it just answer it Nike
just do it do it and I'm correct I can't
believe that's correct no I'm sorry it's
a tits now
um
I'll take anal bum covers for a
thousands
now but but that it's all tied to that
dopamine so that that's why that's why
we needed it we need that thing to tell
us that no in order to survive you need
to get up and go do more you need more
but you don't need more of all this
other [__] which is what's ta it's
hijacking it's literally this is
something we talk about a lot and I bet
you're going to have a great answer to
this not to put there's zero pressure
but like
one of the big things I'm gonna two
things that have changed my life uh one
is if you sort of feel like doing the
hard thing that's as good as it gets
meaning if you sort of feel like Val and
I were talking about that last night I
just had a very inactive day and I sort
of felt like uh walking on the treadmill
which is my exercise yeah I sound like
an old man walk on the treadmill and
then I walked on the treadmill for at
least 30 minutes incline's five baby
come on that's pretty good uh and I was
like we say it Val and I say it all the
time we go if a little bit is as good as
it gets yeah we said if you want to
write a little feeling is as good as it
gets yeah yeah work answer emails
whatever it might be exercise a little
bit is a good that number one number two
is
try to get addicted meaning try to
associate your dopamine your motivating
thing with good things yeah so I'm
curious about your mental health journey
and look I don't mean to put you in a
hole but you seem like a well-defined
healthy person so I'm interested what
are some of the things that you did when
you were struggling with your mental
health that got you to the literal
superhero I think I think shazam's a
documentary the literal superhero but
you know what I mean tell me well I mean
honestly the biggest thing the biggest
thing the biggest thing was learning
that I did not love myself
and I had no idea that I didn't love
myself I had no idea I just assumed you
know I didn't I wasn't I didn't feel
like I was ever actively hating myself
or or disliking myself
so I thought well clearly I love myself
but I didn't how did you find out well
you know one of the one of the
breakthroughs was
um
talking to my you know uh therapists and
them asking me
um you know how do you talk to yourself
with all you know everything all the
darkness I was going through in that
moment or even just you know when I [__]
up or fail or whatever how do you talk
to yourself I'm like I berate myself I'm
like you [__] idiot like why didn't
you do this right and why don't you do
that right and you know I I'm very much
very critical of myself and then one of
them said I mean so simply they said
would you talk that way to anybody
outside of you that you love I said well
of course
oh my God wait do that again and I'll be
and yeah
do it again you'll be you and yeah okay
will you talk to anybody like that
outside of yourself you know that you
love and I'd be like well of course not
who can say where the wind blows and the
children go
good morning
Anya's got bangers bro
particularly you know who loves Daniel
who Eckhart Tolle that actually doesn't
surprise me at all I wouldn't I thought
you're gonna say something like and he
was like let's listen to some music Jaco
willings or something no he loves Daniel
like of course that cart loves Daniel
that's what I'm saying if you get to the
if you pull the plug on the bath and
you're there if you're home yeah and
here's what it sounds like
but you know but that's so that's great
that was a big eye-opening moment and
then and then just other you know other
things that you and again this is why
therapy is a wonderful beautiful thing
that everybody needs to do because we we
as much as we like to believe that we
see ourselves entirely do [__] not we
do not see ourselves we see parts of
ourselves the parts that we see of
ourselves are also very biased and
subjective to just the way we happen to
view the world and that's why we need
people around us you know that iron
sharpening iron that those people that
hold you accountable that are that
mirror it's also referenced in the movie
King of Kong is it really just what yeah
he goes I just says it's Proverbs iron
sharpening oh I don't remember that in
there you love the movie King of Kong
and why and why therapist the licensed
you know professional therapist is so
great because they get to be a really
hopefully intelligent uh uh uh learned
um mirror that is unbiased that it that
has no vested interest in whatever your
healing path is going to be other than
you just have a better understanding of
who you are how the world works and how
you fit into all of that right so the
more I was able to just kind of get
little bits and Bobs more of those
mirrors more of even people around me
and being able to kind of dig deeper
into that that was a huge part of and by
the way and also has become part of a
thing that I'm addicted to I am addicted
to talking about not my self-love but
self but love in general I can't well we
just said addictions yes exactly exactly
this is going back to to your point
which is so that that really helped me
working out you know there's there's no
way of sends us about it but you know
you're when you go and actually use this
meat bag as designed because we have not
evolutionarily passed beyond that we're
still very much physiologically
hunter-gatherers if we are not using our
body in a manner that's similar to that
we are our body's gonna be unhappy so
you want to move you need to move we got
to go and do these things
um
is a respectable incline in a 4.2 it's
not bad it's not bad steady state cardio
by the way that's a great way for
anybody to just start doing some [__]
because it'll get your heart rate up to
the point where that's why I'm doing it
I'm not trying to like break a record
I'm trying to elevate my heart for 30
minutes exactly that's it exactly and
that's good yeah it's good for you yeah
it's base level like at least just go do
that for your heart for your body to get
things to move your anxiety to get that
dopamine for your anxiety all that stuff
yeah my treadmill used to be here and
there's a post that says let your body
solve what your brain can't oh that's
good yeah I love the ROMs there too
there he is man he seems so good people
think that's Alan Alda but
but yeah man you know listen I mean
getting I think I really get addicted to
loving yourself and it's hard because if
you don't start with loving yourself if
you don't start with loving yourself
it's a very difficult thing to get
addicted to but in the same way if
you've never worked out before it's
really hard to get into the groove of
working out until you're working out
enough where all of a sudden it's not so
hard and it's actually you start to
Crave it you start to get that addiction
you're like man I want those endorphins
I feel good in the morning if I get up
and I do that thing I just feel better
in my day yeah getting better sleep is a
part of loving yourself spending time in
deep thought meditative prayer whatever
that is spending time in that being with
yourself not needing to I was constantly
distracting myself with because I was
running from you know um uh I don't know
if you're familiar with the Enneagram at
all but I'm oh oh am I but like by the
way yeah but so uh as a as a hardcore
Enneagram seven I was and by the way
Richard Rohr his Enneagram book is
fantastic a Christian perspective but
very much Taps into yes I'm you know as
a seven I'm an Enthusiast and I want to
do all this stuff but really I'm just
running from Pain and I was running from
pain my whole life I did not want to
feel that pain and so I would go and
distract myself with friends and hanging
out and parties and things and
substances and sex and whatever things
by the way some of these things that I
still will occasionally go and distract
myself with that I still enjoy that I
still go but but I have gotten way
better at recognizing that oh no no no
no no no this is me going for the
cheaper version this is me running from
the pain as opposed to actually being
present and enjoying whatever that
particular thing is and you've got to
get addicted to the you got to get
addicted to the Healthy Man I mean
that's that's what you got to do yeah
yeah you're uh the way Richard was hey
your sin is denial the seven is denial
the well the need to avoid pain is is
what he like it's one of the things I
loved about his particular book was you
know if you read like The Riso Hudson
the wisdom of the Enneagram it's got the
typical you know the reformer or the
Enthusiast the you know whatever
although the Challenger which I think
are very good kind of placeholder names
for these categories of personality but
in in Richard's book he didn't call him
any of those things it was like the need
to control the need to not be controlled
the need to avoid pain it's all these
deep needs in us and for the seven it
was the need to avoid pain at all costs
and that's why gluttony and I also love
that he attached like one of the seven
deadly sins and then like there's the
two extra that are kind of you know kind
of attached to that they could have
sworn one of yours was denial well but
gluttony is certainly was gluttony is
yeah and that's where you've because I'm
trying to avoid pain you're gonna just
be [__] Oh I wanna do all the things
I want it all I want to feel good all
the time right right yours what are you
on the on the I'm a three I'm split
exactly between a three and a four but I
think a three wing Force yeah favor yeah
and deceit is my sin ooh yeah oh
interesting though in order to achieve
yeah yeah to morph and and he who people
want me to be so I can like sneak in and
eat your Donuts
what are we gonna eat my Donuts I'm a
Mormon
met the Mormon party eating their pizza
but that's not even it that's just that
that that's just a thief
um
a lot of my uh Richard thinks this is
such a fun thing to say he always thinks
I'm a seven and I'm like I'm a seven for
you you should see me around other
people yeah yeah yeah yeah and I'm a
seven on this podcast
although the four are in me loves um
it's not moping but Val and I talk a lot
about our feelings and that really works
for me she's a nine which is oh
Peacemaker I mean she's like yeah she's
just wanting it she's a Beach Community
yeah which is great but a nine it's a
Beach Community a nine in half there's a
three so the more Val is in our
relationship which is a very safe and
loving relationship she starts teaching
classes she starts doing all these
things that she just needed to feel
extra safe and then she could become a
three and a three I don't know if it's
in health I think it is in health
becomes a nine so I go towards her and
she goes towards me oh interesting yeah
threes and nines are good for you I
think a seven becomes a five in health
but I'm not I can't even remember really
what a five challenger no no that's the
eight
oh I'm sorry it's the the five is the
investigators yes the investors I always
take that as challenging
that's funny the five is the one that's
like like Michael gungor's a five and I
explained him all that core stuff and he
had a lot more questions and I was like
it's not annoying but I'm like this is
very five yeah
I would rather talk to a seven because a
seven is like oh wow yeah yeah and then
they'll find where they relate yeah and
you get farther I'm not saying you need
the five but you get farther with a
seven and I like go like seeing how far
we can go and then looking behind us and
going like then I don't know that turn
was a little goofy or whatever but let's
go let's take it all away all the way
yeah yeah in in in in unhealth sevens
become ones and in health ones become
sevens which is really interesting like
my sister is a hardcore one and every
time she was like really healthy and
like not stressed out we would really be
getting along because she wanted to have
more fun yeah and anytime I would be
devolving into like the war Oneness
because I've been having too much fun
and now I gotta like really put some
breaks on and I gotta put some you know
I gotta put some order to this and
everything has to have its place or
whatever otherwise I'm like stressing we
would kind of relate on that level it's
a very strange kind of teeter-totter in
that but anyway you gotta you're a very
fast are you feeling the magic mind this
isn't a product placement do you feel I
mean I guess kind of because I I'm
pretty I'm pretty that's just level
always feel like you're this way all the
time yeah yeah yeah I'm listening to you
talking I'm like this is this is a half
speed episode
and I'm like that's why when I gave you
the magic mind I was like I don't I
don't think you know he needs it yeah
are you taking any brain supplements are
you just this way uh no I take some
nootropics yeah yeah I take um uh on it
um Alpha Brain Alpha Brain another
sponsor there you go yeah.com uh but uh
what about your DHA suddenly dropped out
I know after we
I I don't I guess it's not a fear that
other people call [__] on me but I'm
calling [__] on myself I'm also a
product of no no but here's the thing
here's the thing
yeah yeah but but I I guess what I'm
what I'm saying is that I know you're
not feeling judged by me I'm just saying
that is a totally natural thing to feel
obviously when you are awake to all of
the [__] that's going on right and yet
we have to be able to give ourselves the
grace to be up but this is the way the
system is built but how the [__] else do
we get these words out if not through
kind of playing the same system it's
similar to what you said about me you're
like this is the best way for your body
to get protein and of course anyone with
any empathy could understand animal
rights right sure so we're all in the
same but the reason I I circled back to
that is I'm like we're all like you said
doing the best we can in a very flawed
flawed meaning imperfect yeah yeah you
can't take a breath in without killing
microbes and all these different things
like well I mean and even like death and
even going to you know um
because because you know we swung back
around on it but you know just to the
food of it all you've got animal food
you've got you know food that are
animals and food that is plant right
yeah and you got people that are very
adamant like I'm Adam and vegans I am I
do not want any animal to die for my
survival okay yeah here's the Dilemma in
order to grow all the food that you need
to eat as a vegetarian or vegan you have
to plow all these fields that is killing
hundreds if not thousands of smaller
animals
mice and squirrels and oh I've never
heard that yet oh bro yeah you have to
make peace with the the brutality
and it's not easy and by the way more
and more than that just For What It's
Worth science is more and more science
is coming out and data is coming out
that the plants are [__] very
sentient they communicate they
understand [__] they have they they hear
when the there are plants that if you
just play the sound of like grasshoppers
eating them they start to change their
biochemistry because they think they're
being eaten like they're aware
I feel that way Thanksgiving with the
Riff hot riff like I hear you play audio
of my parents arguing I just oh
Thanksgiving people are eating you wow
this is a weird family but this is why
we need uh stories mythologies ways of
understanding that life feeds on death
and that's okay and even even if it's
the death of of plants sure and Grace
with each other if you are like if you
want to be an adamant vegan then do that
if that's what you feel called to your
conscience but recognize that it's not
as black and white as you want it to be
it's not as cut and dry morality as you
want it to be and therefore have Grace
with someone else who's a hardcore
carnivore understand that yes they might
be doing this but they might be killing
one animal at a time right we're back to
the joy of scapegoating and I've I fall
into this too and ramdas if he ever felt
himself being towards the end of his
life he did eat chicken I saw him do it
but he would he tells the story of he
felt himself feeling too righteous that
he didn't eat meat yeah so he went to a
Chinese restaurant and ate spare ribs
and he was in his like his basically his
gown and yeah his businessman comes up
to him and was feeling ramdas's
vibrations and you know it's the 70s and
he just looks like this groovy guy and
the businessman opens up to him any big
heavy guy and he's like I just need to
get it together you see him so together
what do you eat and on the plate in
front of around that's where all these
pig bones but that's it you if you're
humble you'll never stumble yeah like is
is Rich not Richard his father Greg
Boyle
it says that in his books and it's
something that I yeah I try to remember
before I go on stage because sometimes
when I ignite my ego I get a little too
big a little too entitled
uh it's what we're saying yeah it's like
I do try to avoid animal products but if
it starts to get to the point where I
then judge you the devil came in the
back door yeah I kicked him out the
front saying stop murdering animals yeah
and he came in the back and he made me
hate you yeah so I don't believe in the
suffering of animals including you yeah
yeah it's great it's great I mean the
ways in which it becomes so strangely
counter-intuitive in so many ways but
but to your point humility humility
gratitude and Trust yes these three
things if we can practice them on a more
regular level and again at my you know
to to those who are atheists it's trust
in whatever the design that's going on
is this thing that is happening that we
have no control over and if you're of
the of the theist category trusting that
in that same design but that there might
be something behind orchestrating
whatever that is but knowing that we
don't know [__] anything so you gotta
you gotta step into that trust and
obviously you got to step into gratitude
that's all scientifically proven and the
humility is the thing that we all need
more of because we don't again know
[__] anything yeah there is a real
Hubris in even believing that God is mad
at you or that that he's going to kick
you into the furnace there's a
narcissism to that and there's also uh I
know how these things work yeah so
there's a piece in going I don't know
but I'm a part of it and I would say
you're being a part of this is a clue
that you are not an error that you're
not a mistake that you belong and that
you're a part of a thing that in its own
weird way is looking out for itself and
is dignified in its own way and and you
belong yeah basically what I would say I
I completely agree and in that that I
think gives us all the
encouragement to love more yeah because
it's it's getting it's humbling oneself
to get to that to that point of
recognizing that I am this infinitely
small
Speck of sand that is a part of this
infinitely large Mosaic that is
comprised of these infinitely small
specks of sand which means you have this
value this Mosaic only exists with you
as a part of it that's right but also
you're unimportant you are just this
little bit of what all of this [__] is
right and that humility then should lead
to oh and therefore so are they and so
are they and so is everybody else and so
is everything well that's pulling the
plug on the on the on the tub to use the
metaphor I've only used in this one but
that's waking up is recognizing that you
are me and I am you and this is this and
it's all it's all one so to your Speck
of sand thing I would add
it's it's the Paradox that you are
I'm hesitant to say unimportant but like
it's your story isn't the point okay
let's say unimportant I I know how
important is it yeah but that's why I
say infinitely valuable
same thing that birthed the cosmos sure
so infinitely important and unimportant
I'll give you unimportant if you give me
couldn't be more important well that's
why I said it's not but that's why I say
valuable yeah yeah that's why I say oh I
like that infinitely valuable me and for
we are because again I mean I I believe
life is the only real value it's the
only real Miracle it's the only real
thing that is like what the [__] is this
how does this even exist we can explain
almost everything else we cannot explain
this thing there's still this incredible
big mystery right but it's insane and so
valuable and moreover you have an
infinite possibility from when you're a
child basically I mean granted there are
certain physicalities that you're not
going to be able I'm not gonna well
neither of us we're gonna be a center
for the Lakers that was just not in our
genes right we were close we're so close
but
if you still have the ability to kind of
go this infinite amount of different
directions once you're brought into this
world if you decide to go this way you
can go that way and you can go this way
and you can be of service in so many
different ways to this world so you have
like this almost infinite value but also
the world doesn't [__] need you and
or if you're a theist God doesn't need
you God will use whoever God wants to
use you think oh well I'm so special
that I did this thing it's like yeah but
somebody else could have done it
somebody else would have done it you
just happen to do it you should be
grateful that you happen to be used in
that way at that time but that doesn't
actually make you important because
that's why I see the different way that
I would frame it as whatever you do or
don't do your value doesn't increase or
decrease sure because you were born
perfect and you'll you'll quote-unquote
die perfectly and nothing's happening
anyway
there's nothing's happening anyway this
is why I love the dream things don't get
too caught up on what you do or don't do
in the dream realize
that uh you're a part of God's mind or
or or or however else you want to put
that yeah here's why because that gets
rid of guilt and fear and and all of all
of his horrible stuff and then you can
shame and shame yeah so but you know I
found I find that with Father Greg I
found that Earth Richard I found that
with ramdas these are interesting cats
because they they don't talk [__] so how
do you bounce off each other I'm not
saying they're not they're boring you
can have conversations but like these
are people that are really embodying an
aspect of God that I think goes back to
what we were saying earlier can be kind
of
uh hard meaning they love and you can't
do anything to make them love you more I
remember I told Richard Rohr I was going
to name if we had a son I was going to
name him Roar he didn't say anything
and I was like that's a guy who
understands that if he believes in the
myth of specialness he's going to be a
little bit further from the truth yeah
so he just he smiled but he wasn't like
oh God like what I would do yeah yeah
and it's interesting these these people
that's what I mean they're not really
here they're here but they're not here
but they are incredible examples of what
we all I think should be trying to walk
toward I agree and the reason but why
don't we it's because I think we vanish
along the way
yes I don't disagree I I don't disagree
the ego is terrified of that that's the
ego is terrified of that because that is
antithetical to survival if we are
feeling ourselves not being here
individually yeah that feels like dying
yes it is but that is death to the ego
right that is and that's what they're
all that's why the Dark Knight of the
soul is when you realize that spiritual
paths aren't to make you happier and
more prosperous there's something much
more
frightening to the ego yeah that that's
why Saint John of the Cross has those
moments where like [__] nothing's even
up here with me and then just one click
further you go
and it's all Ben and Jerry's baby
all right
Ben and Jerry is uh
weird I know I do try to avoid animal
products but this cow should be very
happy that they're they're making us so
fat can I say that I mean I just said it
you know what
it was just a comedy routine
um thank you Chuck Tangled Shazam this
is this is when the resume gets Broadway
Tony
acting Hiatus uh get addicted to loving
yourself that'll be the quote Yeah
addicted to loving yourself we want to
die amen acting at six uh who cares if
if every guest came like you
you you know what I say this often but
Conan said when Martin Short does his
show
he calls it a day off Zach Levi you're a
day off and that is that's a real gift
brother I well I have so much love and
respect for you honestly I followed you
for many years and I love what you do on
this show and I love what you do with
your comedy but I particularly I like
that you get into these really deep
interesting conversations and you want
to unpack you want to get into it
because so many people don't and it's
like guys there's so much more there's
so much more depth that we can be
getting into and I love that you are a
forum for that and and you are a forum
for that you're not just a platform for
other people to do that you yourself
have a deep desire to want to do that
and I [__] love it so thank you man
you are a seven I love it but
um you are doing the same thing and what
a delight I I really I just had a
feeling it was going to be a great one
and I didn't do I did so little I just
seen so much York anyway I wasn't
worried about that but I wish they could
all be California Girls well and this is
and this is exactly why you know for
anybody who's watching or listening you
know we've been trying to make this
happen for years but for literally years
yeah and but I was always adamant and
you were and you were kind of with me on
it it's like if we can make it happen in
person let's make it happen in person
because this is a way more interesting
way to have conversations you're too not
to say that the guests that do it over
Zoom aren't precious but I was like I
had a feeling
it's not the words that's you're
precious not precious
oh okay uh well thank you would you
please grace us yes with a keep it
crispy
hey guys
I'm gonna need you to keep it crispy you
you sounded like Affleck in there you're
in the DC Universe twice
you are thanks for letting me um come
and make it weird
I made a wonderful and weird yeah
peace out thanks everybody
[Music]